[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ces dossiers sensibles je vais
partager avec vous une interprétation
depuis plus de 20 ans un vrai débat sur
l'indépendance énergétique de la france
est impossible avec l'aide des médias et
des réseaux sociaux
des ong internationales ont commencé par
faire exclure le nucléaire qui
permettait à notre pays d'avoir
l'électricité la moins chère d'europe
puis les écologistes utilisant comme
nouvelle bible les rapports successifs
du giec ont imposé aux politiques et aux
médias de passer au plus vite à leur
solution exclusive
l'énergie renouvelable
l'envolée des prix de l'électricité
depuis l'été et la reprise mondiale
après le coc vide a brutalement rebattu
les cartes dans le fond si personne ne
met en doute la nécessité de prendre des
mesures pour faire face au réchauffement
climatique
il n'empêche que la hausse des prix du
gaz et l'électricité touche directement
au moins 36 millions d'européens selon
thierry breton alors chacun essaie d'y
faire face en italie le premier ministre
mario draghi a pris toute une série de
mesures pour un coût de 3 milliards
d'euros en espagne la tva sur
l'électricité est passée de 21 à 10 % et
il a été décidé une baisse temporaire de
l'impôt sur l'électricité qui est passé
de 5,11 à 0 5% les polonais plus au nord
ont pris des mesures de compensation
pour les 6 % de foyers dont les dépenses
en énergie dépasse 10% de leurs revenus
en france
le président macron inquiet on le
comprend devant la montée du
mécontentement
résultant de la perte de pouvoir d'achat
a donné 100 euros français gagnant moins
de 2000 euros nets par mois et je les
tarifs du gaz d'électricité pour toute
l'année 2020 au-delà de ces mesures
conjoncturelles et français ont
découvert une réalité qu'il n'avait pas
compris ou plutôt qu'on ne leur avait
pas expliquer les engagements pris au
niveau européen sont très contraignants
et coûteux plus grave encore la loi de
2015 relatives à la transition
énergétique pour la croissance verte a
été rédigée puis voter
sans en avoir sérieusement étudié le
coup la faisabilité et les conséquences
comme le souligne un interlocuteur de
géraldine woessner dans le point des
décisions prises ces dernières années
n'ont pas intégré les coûts d'adaptation
du réseau renouvelables la fabrication
moyens de stockage et les solutions pour
pallier à l'intermittence et ceci en les
associant aux différents scénarios à
commencer par celui d'un 100%
renouvelable
aujourd'hui tout le monde prend
conscience qu'il va falloir en assumer
les conséquences
depuis la coop 21 et les décisions
prises à bruxelles les pays européens
doivent électrifié massivement leurs
économies afin de ne plus avoir à
utiliser d'énergies fossiles en 2050
ceci implique de trouver des solutions
pour remplacer les moteurs actuels dans
quantité de domaines d'activité comme
les transports par exemple c'est un
engagement difficile car aujourd'hui le
mix énergétique européen
reste dominé par les énergies fossiles
comme l'a rappelé ramona bloch de la
fondation robert schuman dans questions
d'europe numéro 6 en 12 38 % de la
consommation d'énergie revient du pétrin
23 % du gaz naturel et 13% du charbon
alors que le nucléaire ne représente que
11% et les énergies renouvelables 19% on
peut ajouter que la dépendance
énergétique de l'europe envers
l'extérieur
était de 55 7% en 2018
dont environ un tiers dépendant de la
russie
l'incapacité des dirigeants de l'union
européenne à se mettre d'accord le 27
octobre face à la flambée des prix de
l'énergie met en valeur trois réalités
il va falloir prendre en compte la
première tient à la situation très
différente selon les pays l'émission de
co2 qui est le plus gros contributeur
aux effets de serre est liée au poids
économique et cela nous savons depuis
longtemps
selon le chapitre environnement énergie
du 28 octobre du site
touteleurope.eu l'allemagne et donc sans
surprise le plus gros émetteur global
mais ramenés par habitant cela
représente 10,7 pour cent tonnes par
habitant quand le portugal est à 20,3 et
la france à 6,9 en ce qui concerne la
pollution par les particules fines
elisabeth pu dans business insider point
fr de mars 2010neuf placé la france en
dixième position des pays européens les
moins polluants quand l'allemagne est le
dixième des pays les plus polluants de
surcroît la production d'électricité
utilisent des sources d'énergie très
différents selon les pays comme
l'indiquent l'excellent article déjà
cité de ramona vologe les énergies
renouvelables représentent en 2010 9 34
% de la consommation brute d'électricité
dans l'union européenne dont les deux
tiers viennent de l'éolien et de
l'hydraulique qui ne faut pas oublier
mais les différences sont énormes entre
la suède il sait 56 % d'énergies
renouvelables et le luxembourg à 7% ou
les pays-bas 8 8% de même la situation
n'est pas la même dans le sud de
l'europe que dans les anciens pays de
l'est ou une énergie fossiles comme le
charbon représente
90% de l'énergie électrique en pologne
et le nucléaire 46% hongrie et 19% en
roumanie
ces situations contrastées explique les
différences de stratégie entre les pays
européens
après avoir analysé et valoriser les six
stratégies possibles pour la france
permettant de réduire ses émissions de
carbone de 40% selon les objectifs qui
ont été fixés
le rapport de rte et de l' agence
internationale de l'énergie sur les
futurs énergétique en 2050 indique qu'il
faudra s'appuyer sur le nucléaire et les
renouvelables il n'est donc plus
question de fermer 14 réacteurs pour
réduire à 50% la part du nucléaire en
2035 comme s'y était engagé les
présidents françois hollande puis
emmanuel macron il est même question de
construire au moins six paires et de
nombreux autres plus petits mais cela va
prendre du temps car la france a perdu
une partie de ses compétences dans ce
domaine durant les vingt dernières
années sous la pression excessive
les écologistes et des anti nucléaires
comme le rappelait récemment arnaud
montebourg il aura fallu que le giec
confirme que le nucléaire était une
énergie utile dans une politique de
décarbonation pour que nos politiques
reviennent à la raison mais pour réussir
le pari
d'atteindre la neutralité carbone il
faudra également continuer à développer
les éoliennes les panneaux solaire et
l'hydraulique dans un mix harmonieux
sachant comme le rappelait nicolas ciel
dans challenges que l'état doit
renégocier ses prix d'achat trop élevé
il faudra aussi comme la chine ou
l'allemagne
avancé sur l'utilisation de l'hydrogène
l'allemagne est dans une toute autre
logique
l'arrêt du nucléaire décidée par la
chancelière angela merkel pour des
raisons purement électorales a été une
catastrophe car la montée en puissance
des énergies renouvelables a été
notoirement insuffisantes malgré les 500
milliards d'euros dépensés il a fallu
rouvrir des centrales à charbon très
polluantes pour le pays et la zone
limitrophe dont l'est de la france elles
vont être progressivement remplacées par
des centrales au gaz qui est le moins
polluant des énergies fossiles a
provisionné principalement par la russie
via l'ukraine et le north stream 2 dont
on a tant parlé c'est pourquoi
l'allemagne à bruxelles soutenu par la
suède et les pays bas
affirmé qu'elle n'avait pas de problème
de gaz ayant obtenu des contrats
privilégiées elle n'était donc pas
intéressé par la proposition des pays du
sud l'espagne l'italie et la grèce de
faire des achats groupés pour faire
baisser le prix du gaz
parallèlement l'allemagne devenue comme
vous le savez puisque nous en avons
parlé dans une émission récente l'europe
du gaz russe en europe veut sécuriser
ses débouchés c'est pourquoi elle
s'oppose à la stratégie nucléaire de la
france de la pologne de la roumanie de
la hongrie et de la finlande selon ce
journal les échos tout ceci aurait
pourtant à bruxelles souligné le rôle
stabilisateur à long terme de l'énergie
nucléaire qui permet de pallier aux
variations des énergies renouvelables
sans dégager de co2 al'inverse du gaz
la troisième réalité tient à
l'impossible rentabilité à court et
moyen terme des énergies renouvelables
l'objectif zéro carbone qui oblige à une
réduction drastique des gaz à effet de
serre en conformité avec l'accord de
paris va être très coûteux le projet fit
for 55 de l'union européenne qui propose
de passer en 2030 d'un objectif de -40%
à moins 55% de carbone par rapport à
l'année de référence
1990 va encore augmenter
et du coup on assiste à l'arrivée de
fonds de pension et d'investissement sur
le marché carbone qui peut être un
excellent placement d'ailleurs la
république tchèque et si vous l'avez lu
aussi d'autres pays de l'est de l'europe
soupçonne dans la hausse actuelle des
manipulations de spéculateurs comme nous
l'avons connu dans le passé sur le
marché des devises et on peut ajouter
entre nous que la france a souffert il
ya quelques années d'une des plus
grosses escroqueries envers l'état avec
la taxe carbone et il faut s'en souvenir
ce que la plupart de nos concitoyens
n'ont pas compris comme l'a expliqué
jean pisani ferry
c'est que la taxe carbone est un prix
que l'on met sur une ressource qui était
jusque-là gratuite quoi qu'on en dise
elle est un coup supplémentaire pour le
consommateur final la tarification de la
tonne de carbone qui était de 30 euros
en début d'année est passé à 65 euros
et devrait atteindre selon la plupart
des analystes
98 euros en 2030 cette remontée
s'explique par le coût des réductions
des émissions au fur et à mesure de
l'inclusion de nouveaux domaines comme
l'aviation ou le transport maritime
intérêts européens
elle servira aussi bon la fermeture des
centrales à charbon dont le coût d'achat
inférieur au gaz devra être compensée
par la taxe sinon je projette entre 2040
et 2050
on évalue aujourd'hui entre 150 et 200
euros le niveau de la taxe carbone pour
atteindre des objectifs fixés sachant
qu'en france selon les experts dans un
document privé qui circulent sur le net
une hausse de 1 euro par tonne de la
taxe carbone augmente le prix de
l'électricité de l'ordre de 0,5 euros
par mégawatt heure on comprend mieux la
position de la hongrie pour qui cette
inflation du prix va tuer la classe
moyenne européenne
aujourd'hui j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
k rowling à l'acte et ross présidente du
pôle de géostratégie réaliste géo pragma
à qui j'ai demandé de bien vouloir
réagir et compléter mon interprétation
bonjour caroline françois la caroline
j'ai beaucoup parlé de l'europe mais les
occidentaux accusent la russie de
déstabiliser les marchés énergétiques en
ne livrant pas suffisamment de gaz qu'en
pensez vous l'ua est en crise parce
qu'elle dépend des marchés volatiles du
gaz naturel liquéfié or tout cela c'est
donc le reflet en fait d'un conflit plus
large dont elle n'est que la proie est
aujourd'hui la victime
et qui à mon sens et bien réunis et et
voit s'opposer les états unis d'un côté
et de l'autre côté la russie bien sûr et
la chine en arrière fond dont il faut
aussi parler pourquoi parce qu'en fait
depuis dix ans depuis 2009 2010 à peu
près on a eu ce qu'on a appelé la
révolution des gaz de schiste jusqu
alors les états unis et bien avait une
politique d'indépendance énergétique
depuis nixon et ils ont fini avec cette
révolution par devenir le premier
producteur mondial
de gaz naturel liquéfié le gaz naturel
liquéfié non seulement ça alors à donner
leur indépendance énergétique vis-à-vis
de leurs anciens fournisseurs
moyen-orientaux et ça ça a des
conséquences géopolitiques considérable
mais ça évidemment ça les a ça les fait
se redéployer vers une stratégie
beaucoup plus agressif de domination
énergétique et ils veulent donc en fait
ravir
la couronne à la russie d'ailleurs ils
l'ont fait comme producteur de gaz et
bien sûr de venir les fournisseurs sinon
exclusive du moins largement majoritaire
de l'union européenne
etc ce conflit qui est en cours donc
évidemment les accusations contre le gaz
russe est contre la dépendance russes
sont fondées parce que cette dépendance
est encore réel c'est près de 40% encore
aujourd'hui mais le gaz naturel liquéfié
américain grignote ses parts de marché
et déjà à 10% alors évidemment les
européens sont dans une joie cornélien
parce que le gaz le gnl comme on
l'appelle il est évidemment beaucoup
plus cher que le gaz russe pour diverses
raisons d'abord parce qu'il faut le
transporter donc il dépend du prix du
pétrole
ensuite parce que il n'ya pas cette
proximité si vous voulez géographique
des gazoducs d'où toutes les toutous le
discours et toutes les luttes autour et
bien des projets russes achevée en
l'espèce de nord stream 2 dont on a
beaucoup entendu parler voilà donc c'est
pour moi il ya vraiment un arrière-fond
global très lourd qui est finalement qui
va dominer l'europe est ce qu'elle va
rester sous une tutelle énergétiques
russes
importante ou bien ce qu'elle va passer
sous dépendance américaine et à partir
de ce moment là la question intéressante
c'est que va faire la russie parce
qu'elle a aussi d'autres intérêts et
d'autres possibilités et comment les
européens vont ils finalement s'en
sortir parce qu'une fois qu'on sera
complètement sous dépendance américaine
on sera à passer d'une tutelle vers une
autre en justement les européens ont
tendance actuellement semble en tout cas
s'intéresser de plus en plus au gaz au
gaz américain qui est pourtant plus cher
que le gaz russe et d'un autre côté pour
nous français par exemple qui avons
interdit la recherche la production et
la vente et la consommation de gaz de
schiste on va acheter dans ce cadre-là
du gaz américain qui est du gaz ici du
schiste donc on est en contradiction
avec nos propres lois en faisant ça dans
le cadre de ce coup venir expliquer et
d'un autre côté les allemands on peut se
poser aussi la question avec les alors
parce que ils sont essentiellement 7e le
hub russe sur l'europe sur l'union
européenne donc eux n'ont pas
véritablement intérêt à abandonner cette
puissance qu'il a redonné par le gaz
russe qu'ils réparties dans toute
l'europe au profit des américains donc
comment vous voyez comment vous
ressentez tout ça parce que c'est
compliqué mais oui c'est compliqué c'est
un billard à plusieurs bandes
donc il y avait un certain nombre de
sujets qui ont montré que la russie
finalement à ce stade
honore ses engagements vis-à-vis de
l'europe et notamment vis-à-vis de
l'allemagne et deuxièmement ne peut pas
non plus faire tout ce qu'on attend
d'elle et elle a donc c'est de bonne
guerre une stratégie très opportuniste
qui est finalement de renforcer ses
positions en même temps elle n'a pas
intérêt à ce que les entreprises
européennes voient les prix du gaz
explosé et son temps soit en faillite
parce que ce sont quand même ses clients
finaux donc c'est une c'est une ligne de
crête après la position de l'allemagne
donc vis-à-vis de la russie
sur cette question énergétique
fondamental pour elle ne peut pas bouger
il y a d'ailleurs eu une un accord enfin
une déclaration en tout cas entre le
président byden et la chancelière merkel
en juillet dernier disant que eh bien
oui
nord stream
même si ça n'est pas encore totalement
mises en place mais on ne pourrait pas
arrêté on ne pourrait pas empêcher nord
stream 2 d'être mises en oeuvre et
d'être mise en activité in fine et mais
les américains par ailleurs et c'est de
grignoter d'autres positions
de de faire en sorte finalement que ce
choix énergétiques qui devrait être
assez naturel est assez évident soit
moins que jamais un choix rationnel et
c'est là qu'on a un problème
géopolitique
parce qu'en fait l'europe sur cette
question énergétique fondamental pour
elle son avenir son développement son
économie sa croissance
va être contrainte j'allais dire à faire
un choix idéologique
qui va lui coûter fort cher
qui ne va pas forcément lui rapporter sa
liberté loin de là
qui valait mettre entre les mains
américaines
pour son sens pour ses fournitures en
gaz et il faut pas oublier que quand on
parle sans arrêt d'énergies
renouvelables ou d'électrification
de l'europe oui c'est formidable mais
l'électricité vient du gaz voilà donc
derrière cette guerre est très
importante et l'idée est évidemment non
seulement de casser
le lien
entre l'europe et la russie au plan
énergétique
mais progressivement aussi parce que
c'est une autre dimension du problème de
pousser la russie à chercher d'autres
débouchés pour ses productions on sait
qu'il y aille à mal
qui est aussi un immense projet voilà
dont on peut parler qu'ils mangeaient de
livraisons de gaz vers la chine voilà il
ya un point sur lequel et on est obligés
quand on voit qu'on couvre comme ça le
marché que vous venez de le faire il ya
un point mais depuis j'ai regardé c'est
la chine plus gros premier consommateur
de gaz mondiales et caisses comment
comment se positionne la chine par
rapport à ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
est comme vous des durs en particulier
avec la russie parce que là il ya des
choses qui se passe est importante il ya
beaucoup de choses qui se passent et ça
c'est dans le cadre d'une bascule plus
global qui n'est pas seulement
énergétique qui est une bascule
géopolitique lourde
dans laquelle nous avons pris une part
selon moi malheureuse est inconsciente
mais enfin qui chaque jour avance un peu
plus ce qui est effectivement de faire
en sorte que la russie qui est
aussi désormais est clairement
en matière énergétique par rapport à
l'europe et bien cherche à se balancer
une partie de ses ressources de ses
productions je parle même pas des
sanctions et c'est vers la chine qui
elle a un besoin considérable d'énergie
même si on peut dire qu'en ce moment il
ya un petit ralentissement et ses
enfants l'économie chinoise elle a
besoin elle a besoin d'énergie elle a
besoin de gaz moscou a aussi des projets
avec pékin de mise en place de petits
réacteurs nucléaires dont il ya aussi
tout un projet de coopération nucléaire
important qui se nouent
et ont je pense qu en europe pour ne
mesure pas la vulnérabilité qui va
devenir progressivement la nôtre au nom
direct on veut on nous faire croire de
notre liberté et de notre émancipation
vis-à-vis de la russie donc c'est assez
s'éteint c'est un vrai paradoxe est en
fait tout ça s'insère voilà dans cette
dans cette nouvelle bipolarité tenté par
l'amérique vis-à-vis de pékin en
récupérant au passage et en tenant d'une
main très ferme l'union européenne dans
tous les domaines merci et caroline pour
ces éclaircissements qui songent pas
très intéressant parce que ça permet
effectivement de compléter un peu ce que
j'avais dit tout à l'heure entendez du
coup de projecteur sur les problèmes qui
sont essentiels ceux ci on est bien
d'accord là dessus merci et puis à très
bientôt j'espère
la commission européenne pour accélérer
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
vont renchérir le prix des émissions de
carbone résidentiel et dans les
transports notre pays s'est engagé sur
un programme dont l'étude annuelle de
rexecode qui vient de paraître montre
que malgré tous nos efforts nous serons
en retard sur les objectifs en 2030 dans
le même temps la croissance pro
française programmée va générer plus
émissions co2 bus de croissance une
émission c'est normal il va donc falloir
investir encore plus pour décarbonée
mais alors qui va le faire les
investisseurs l'état par des impôts
nouveaux ou les fabricants par des taxes
imposées dans tous les cas de figure
ceci aura un impact direct sur notre
niveau de vie à bientôt
[Musique]